we need you know to reform that  gun shouldn't be as easily accessible  like it's easier to get a gun than baby  formula right now uh  that's unbelievable and you know this  country that we live in  um  and also for you know  i i don't like bringing things on you  know about myself but i mean i  have a kid now and you know me and my  wife were talking before the game just  about  like  how scary it is that you have a child  obviously he's not  old enough to go to school but when that  does happen how  you know crazy the world is and just how  much i mean honestly i feel like we all  need to pray  figure out you know pray to whoever  whoever you pray to um  get right with you know jesus get right  with the lord and then just obviously we  need to figure out this  gun control thing because  this is ridiculous there's been  104 now it's been 140 some days  there's been 27 school shootings and  212 overall  shootings in the country  that's ridiculous